do you know what the greatest thing
about America is you can make things
happen here like nowhere else
you can be anything you can do anything
you want to sell high-end stuffed
Himalayan cats under stuffed actually
for greater posability we're
professionals we're giving the people
what they need
did you see the latest numbers we broke
the entire internet thing
Ben or you go home
[Music]
I would tell you he did it all
wishes as crazy as believing stuffed
animals are gold
do you see the truck crash
insane poor beanies
this has always been my company company
we created together you have to be so
dramatic I mean my salary's been reduced
75 yeah I'm just doing what's necessary
you know running the real actual
business over here
that man you can eat out of town my life
is this company can I see where it's
going
there are signs of real trouble genius
is one percent inspiration 99
presentation
that's not how the saying goes
[Music]
everything good that's happened to me is
because of you guys we are bonded
forever
have you considered poisoning him
countless times
[Music]
I have our perfect Partners lined up
Jehovah's Witnesses the greatest
one-on-one salesman in the world how
brilliant is that
[Music]
um
is
I only want to speak to Oprah Winfrey
has she reached out